Monaco is a tiny Nation here nuzzled
into the southern coast of France its
people speak French and Italian and as
you'll likely know during the early
modern and modern periods there was a
real push to get people who spoke the
same language to become a part of the
same country yet Monaco despite its size
managed to Dodge Conquest and nationally
sentiment to remain independent to this
day which raises a pretty obvious
question why does Monaco exist and how
did it avoid becoming a part of France
or Italy Monaco has existed as an
independent entity since the 13th
century and its ruling house the house
of Grimaldi had one objective don't get
conquered and to do this it had one very
clever plan placing itself under the
protection and vassalage of its much
more powerful neighbors the grimaldis
were subjects of the genoese the French
and later the Spanish whom they promised
to be loyal to that was of course until
it was no longer convenient and so in
the early 17th century Monaco's rulers
instead approached the French King for
protection he said yes of course because
no self-respecting king of France could
resist an opportunity to deprive Spain
of subjects and after this Monica
remained a French protector at for
nearly 200 years things changed though
when some Chaps in France got some new
ideas about monarchs and stuff in 1793
the French Republic conquered Monaco and
Incorporated it into the country and
soon it was Napoleon's turn to fight
everyone and after he lost the great
Powers opted to restore Monaco to its
independence in 1814. the king of
Sardinia was none too happy with this
Arrangement because Kings like having
more land and so to shut him up Monaco
was made of Sardinian protectorate the
next year and interestingly this
decision to make it a puppet state was
what saved Monaco from becoming a part
of another country as you'll be aware
the sardinians had plans for building in
Italy and given that Monaco was already
a protectorate there was no need for
Sardinia to conquer it in fact like much
of Europe Monaco wasn't free from the
forces of revolution in 1848 as a result
of its revolution most of the country
broke away and soon after became a
separate protectorate of Sardinia
although sardini didn't Annex these
lands because they didn't want to upset
the French who had their eyes on the
region in return for French support in
defeating the Austrian sardini as he did
these lands to them and for the French
the unclear status of these lands meant
that France was free to take it for
itself which the ruling Prince of Monaco
had to accept because well what was he
going to do about it the French decided
not to Annex all of Monaco at this point
because Napoleon III didn't want to give
the rest of the great Powers who had
agreed that Monaco should be independent
to have any reason to oppose him which
allowed Monaco to remain independent
without France thinking too much about
it you see after Monaco had lost most of
its land it needed to find other ways to
make money and it did this via two
methods gambling and later on evasive
accounting Charles diggle was annoyed
that his citizens could Dodge taxes in
Monaco and so he closed the border with
the country the Prince of Monaco
panicked because he thought that the
ghoul was going to Annex his country and
so he made a deal Monaco would clamp
down on the French dodging taxes there
and France would in return calm down
this worked and thereafter Monaco's
Independence was Secure so long as it
didn't act against France's interests I
hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons James
bizzinette Kelly moneymaker call show
wolf Sky Chappelle kartoitska Jerry
lambdin Alex Schwinn Adam Stalter Jordan
Longley rod D Martin why in hockey
Marcus Arsenal Captain psydog Marvin
Castle Spencer Lightfoot Winston caywood
boogly Wiggly Daniel tobian commune Miss
izet Gustav Swan Aaron the white Anthony
Beckett the mcwhopper Maggie Paskowski
Coppertone spinning three plates she
went in words about books podcast and
Charles the first